this is what's left of the warehouse in
a town bordering Malaysia
Twisted Metal and Rubble are all that
remain
nearly a ton of illegally stove
fireworks exploded igniting a fire
the number of the injured is around a
hundred we have set up a station to
receive a report on casualties and
damage
more than 200 houses surrounding the
warehouse have been damaged forcing
families to move to a shelter
he went on for an hour before the
explosion stopped it was chaotic we
stuck to each other here and there we
didn't know what to do
police are now investigating the cause
of the explosion residents say warnings
about dangerous goods being stored at
the warehouse have long been ignored
it's scary because I've warned them not
to build a warehouse because it's
dangerous if it exploded the impact
radius would be 10 kilometers why do
they have to build it near the community
but no one cared to listen to my advice
and this has happened
police say the owner of the factory will
be charged with negligence
foreign